it's the end of an era Trevor Noah quits
The Daily Show after walkery saw viewing
figures slumped to around 363 363
000 a show seven years were taking over
from Jon Stewart who routinely pulled in
an audience of 1.5 million yeah I do
think wilkry played a role but I also
think it's just a change in how media is
being consumed I think Jon Stewart was
the real talent Trevor Noah was kind of
a nobody so he couldn't really pull
anything in yeah and also who's going to
be watching this year yeah Jon Stewart
built that show Trevor Noah just
inherited it uh but this is but this is
still good news yes I think Trevor Noah
was was bad he had half truths and
misinformation consistently on his show
that he wouldn't fact check and uh these
are the kind of people that believed
Russia gate Ukraine gate hands up don't
shoot Ahmed Arbury you know the Trayvon
Martin stuff they believed all the lies
the manipulations
so seeing him go
I was talking about this earlier
it is the end of an era the corporate
establishment the woke establishment
they are dwindling